it's the first trip to china by a u.n
human rights commissioner since 2005.
but details of michelle bachelet's visit
have been hard to come by
over six days she spent time in
guangzhou in china's south as well as
the cities of uramuchi and kashgar in
xinjiang province
due to strict coronavirus regulations no
reporters were allowed to travel with
her and many of her meetings including
with president xi jinping have taken
place online because for me
it is a priority to engage with the
government of china directly
to see how we can collaborate
on human rights issues domestically
regional and global
for development peace and security being
sustainable locally and across borders
human rights have to be at the core
activists say government controls have
prevented bachelet from clearly
assessing alleged atrocities taking
place against the uyghur people
her visit was first planned in 2018
following widespread allegations that
china was subjecting uigas to forced
labor sterilization and torture and
several governments and rights groups
say beijing is guilty of carrying out
genocide
i doubt she would have unfettered access
to
the region i doubt that she would be
able to talk to the victims of the
government's abuses
so you know i don't have high hopes
attention on xinjiang has intensified
this week following an unprecedented
leak of police files purporting to
reveal bleak conditions inside one of
the province's notorious internment
camps
thousands of mugshots and documents
including a speech ordering guards to
shoot and kill those who try to flee
challenge china's description of the
camps as voluntary vocational training
centers it's nothing to do with poverty
elevation
nothing to do with helping people to get
jobs it's about brutal brainwashing it's
about putting them in prison-like prison
camps guarded by heavily armed police
beijing has denied accusations of
mistreatment calling them the lie of the
century it says its policies in the
region are designed to stamp out
terrorism
xi jinping defended china's human rights
record on wednesday saying it would not
be patronized by other countries
michelle bachelet says her trip is not
an investigation but a mission to
promote human rights but critics fear
there's little it will achieve katrina
you al jazeera beijing